more canadians have been infected with
covid19 during this wave than any before
but more have also been vaccinated it's
better to be secure than you know the
latest data showed just over a third of
canadians already have a third dose but
new ipsos polling conducted for global
news reveals many aren't eager to get
additional shots beyond that more than
half 56 percent express some concern and
wonder how many more we may need i think
it's ridiculous to think that we should
be getting you know a vaccine every four
or six months
you know indefinitely data from israel
found fourth doses less effective
against omicron experts here agree
immunocompromised people warrant an
additional boost but there isn't a clear
consensus for everyone else we need to
see now
what will happen to
protection over time
with their doses vaccine manufacturers
aren't waiting moderna says it hopes to
produce a shot capable of tackling
multiple variants the point of actually
creating boosters that have different
vaccine sort of
strains inside of them is to actually
shock your immune system a little bit
and get it to grow and broaden its
immune response the company is also in
phase two trials for a combined flu
covet rsv vaccine but dr peter hotez one
of the developers of a patent-free coven
vaccine formula says until we vaccinate
the world new mutations will emerge
mother nature's not being coy with us
she's telling us what she's going to do
because she's done it twice it's going
to happen again we are going to have
another major variant of concern
canada's top doctor says we aren't ready
to commit to a new vaccine strategy i
think the global opinion at this point
is that the omicron virus is going to be
with us for some time so we do need to
take a longer term approach waiting for
more data to make a decision that will
ultimately impact canadians health for
years to come jamie marrocker global
news toronto